space the final frontier
our continuing mission to seek out new
life and new civilizations and leave
them alone to trade with them if they
want but to mostly leave them alone
[Music]
I would like a large Cola your choice is
unavailable fragra your choice is
unavailable milk unpasteurized your
choice is unavailable decent cheese your
choice is unavailable cake your choice
is unavailable it's a wedding cake for
my friend Sulu who's marrying a guy you
win this time huh all we did was add
private property rights a little bit of
financial incentive and they're off the
endangered species list you don't see
anybody running out of chickens computer
run program trump presidency in programs
computer run program Clinton presidency
and programs Google Gary Johnson
it's nice but I just don't want to throw
my vote away
okay so to recap go back in time find
some whales save the planet Earth
Standard Shatner maneuver we're counting
on you captain while I have you I want
to talk to you about the inertial
dampers what about them the slightest
impact inertial dampeners offline these
panels explode and some guy in a red
shirt flies over the railing look that
ship hears there's nothing but a port
project the Federation didn't need 16
new Galaxy class cruisers Congress
ordered them and for what to seek out
new life and new so presenting so they
could transfer money into their
congressional districts you realize that
every single piece on that ship is
manufactured in a completely separate
star system right I mean what sense does
that make
unless it's nothing but a galaxy-wide
jobs program but hey we're both getting
checks so shut up live long and prosper
at the expense of taxpayers campin is
offline does this really need to be a
thing prayer and God are still not
allowed in America's schools head
coordinates to beam it back where it
came from beam me up ladies and
gentlemen this is the year Bitcoin takes
on doesn't bother you the killings ever
pass a test tim is the Kobayashi Maru no
one passes the test test itself is a
cheat you programmed it to be unwinnable
your argument for cludes the possibility
of a no-win scenario I don't believe in
no-win scenarios
no phasers no tricorders if I catch you
with the tricorder you will not make
this transport all right I don't care
what war you served in ma'am
weapons locked on Starfleet coordinates
captain fire firing direct hit damage
report
oh that was a wedding what we bombed a
wedding okay
lieutenant can you give me one of those
forms again please afraid we've run out
of those forms captain computer
replicate fruit basket your choice is
not available it's a gay fruit basket
all right beam it down and then punch it
[Music]